انس نتابع معك تفاصيل هذا الحصار للمبنى
التابع للهلال الاحمر في
جباليه طبعا قوات الاحتلال منذ امس وهي
تحاصر هذا المبنى والذي يضم رجال الهلال
الاحمر وايضا وجود جرحى في داخل هذا
المبنى في جباليه اي ايضا يتم اطلاق النار
عليهم واطلاق قذائف المدفعيه حسب احد
المسعفين المحاصرين في داخل هذه المبنى لا
احد يتحرك من المبنى ولا يستطيع التنقل من
المكان مازال محاصره المبنى حتى هذه
اللحظه منذ امس لا يتوفر اي امكانيات
عندهم المبنى يوجد فيه مسعفون ويوجد فيه
شرع جرحه في هذا المكان لا احد يستطيع
الوصول لهذا المكان او الخروج من هذا
المكان حتى اللحظه مازالوا محاصرين في هذا
المبنى واطلاق النار عليهم بشكل متواصل من
قبل قوات الاحتلال طبعا منذ الليله ل
الغارات لم تتوقف على جباليا البلد وعلى
مخيم جباليا اكثر من 200 غاره كانت هذه
الليله حتى هذه اللحظه ما زالت الغارات
مستمره القصف المدفعي لم يتوقف ايضا القصف
بالطائرات الحربيه لم يتوقف في هذه
الاماكن فقط لو تسمح لي قبل الدخول في هذه
التفاصيل كم عدد المسعفون وال الجرحى
المتواجدين داخل هذا المبنى
المحاصر يوجد عشرات داخل هذا المبنى
المحاصر لكن لم يحدد العدد بالتحديد يعني
في داخل المبنى لكن يوجد عشرات من
المسعفون ومن الطواقم المتواجده داخل هذا
المبنى هذا المبنى هو المقر الرئيسي
للهلال الاحمر في هذه المنطقه يوجد يقومون
بتقديم الخدمات للجرحى في هذا المبنى فتم
محاصره المبنى وحتى هذه اللحظه مازال
محاصر المبنى هو ومن داخله ويتم اطلاق
النار عليهم ايضا تتواجد اليات الاحتلال
في محيط هذا المبنى الان اليات الاحتلال
تقاصر هذا المبنى